[Music]
welcome back to author record where
we're talking about
whatever we want hey we got anime back
hey
all right what's wrong dude chilling bro
what's that band-aid all about is that a
a statement piece
so like i just learned how to use a
circular saw you know
i didn't learn how to not get hit by the
shield
flexi glass oh [ __ ] so yeah i might
still have some
in my skin you want to show the wound do
you use goggles iron man
no i don't don't i will now but yeah i
didn't then
what are you making uh i made a ball pit
where the sides are see-through so if
you were taking a photo
you can like be under the balls oh
that's a lot of balls
like the sound of that for your photos
video this isn't the billy studio this
is the
boxy in the second c studio did you buy
ball
ball pit balls and everything yeah they
cost a ton really
buy them from like a freaking guy who
buys them from china resells them here
in like arizona who has specials and
goes this month i'm selling all shades
of blue
for like 500 bucks what color did you
get uh
pink and black
the pink and black deal was even better
black pink
yeah exactly nice just to catch everyone
up ryan
has two studios now two photos yeah yeah
yeah yeah one one
of the cruel themes like shredded denim
walls like i didn't know that
yeah tell them about your studio yeah uh
yeah it's a content studio
different sets uh yeah check the link
if there is one it's right here how do
people even know to take pictures
at your place how do they know to take
pictures like where do you put it up
like on oh it's on pure space
oh that's why yeah it's it's a peer
space studio yeah
is that a good business it's good yeah
i'm here to take pictures
yeah it's easy is there rules like no
blow jobs in porn
uh anal is fine blow jobs are okay
okay porn is not okay that's what
happens
like the simulated like ronald mcdonald
you know the girls always blow around
down oh yeah on the
how did you get into this uh because i
used to produce like
different videos for other people and i
would rent peer spaces and then i would
go
damn this [ __ ] sucks it should have this
and that and then
just make one you know rather than
complain about them so what's your
favorite room in there
business backdrop i think i like 70 [ __ ]
i mean
if you guys look at the place it's a
collection of most of my old [ __ ]
that i like to collect like just junk oh
that's dope so you just have like
props and art direction laying around
yeah yeah yeah but like ryan's junk is
like really cool it's not like our junk
i see my truck sucks dude you can't make
a room out of my junk
i don't have junk this is the kind of
[ __ ] that my mom would be like see i'm a
hoarder but
i made a business out of it yeah it is
it's actually a good business for orders
yeah ryan's like the best type of mom
out there seriously
i'll be a great mom eventually that's
your least favorite backdrop at this
place
i mean it's a standard thing that most
studios have like the giant white
infinity wall that's my least favorite
because it costs the most to like
you gotta paint it all the time yeah oh
yeah we had one feet get on there and
stuff right yeah it gets dirty all the
time like
and then plus like dude one time i mean
this is the worst incident i've ever had
but a dude at a video shoot forced
himself to vomit all over the wall
why why because [ __ ] rock and roll
because rock and roll one piece of [ __ ]
yeah did he did he clean it though
yeah but like he cleaned it but that's
not okay but he wasn't supposed to do it
he's like i know i throw up but i'm
gonna clean the door like what the [ __ ]
about joe i cleaned it mentality he
should have told you he should have told
you he's gonna throw up
and then you would be like no don't come
here i think he had enough decency to
clean it
because i for me i don't i've thrown up
plenty of times in my works of art
never [ __ ] clean it other people do
it for me
he's the manager of the rock band i know
he's like it's fine let him do it
yeah we could hear him talking about
like i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it his
friend's like yeah you should totally do
it you're smelling my ass
does it and then i go out there and the
guy's like oh man i'm sick i ate a
burrito uh
like trying to have a story for it and
we're like dude the whole narrative is
on camera
[Laughter]
better video than whatever the [ __ ] you
shot did you guys charge extra for it
yeah
yeah we had to because it was like right
when kovitz started too so we're uh
we're in here like smelling these dudes
burrito fumes
oh like come on man how do you make
himself throw up they were just going oh
yeah but why why before rock and roll is
that rock and roll
yeah man when i was uh at ucb it was
like 2007.
i was interning so we had to clean up
after everything and there was a
midnight show
where guys would like take shits on
stage and
one time a dude took out a fish that he
just bought at the gelsons right next to
it and he started [ __ ] it
that's different this is ucb yeah when
was this 2007.
um maybe 2007 maybe i missed something
you could do that at ucb
yeah the midnight face [ __ ] it that's
funny though that's funny
it's like a [ __ ] on the stage that's
also funnier than you throwing and then
you were in charge of cleaning it as an
intern shut up [ __ ] no i was i have
dignity throwing up for rock and roll
i've always been more like a groundlings
type of guy
prop comedy i'm taking a cone and uh
shouting at your neighbor
no groundling a street performer in new
york take a [ __ ] in a mop bucket
really oh yeah and then i realized he
was homeless
is that the dude that video where he's
trying to fight the guy yeah
someone told me that one was staged it
seemed so real though
that stage that stated to be true
because it's such a perfect situation
the angle's just set up a camera is
there
and his shit's all shaped nice yeah dude
yeah it's the perfect [ __ ]
i don't know man i think i've seen too
many homeless people [ __ ] to think
that that's too yeah i've seen uh
homeless guys [ __ ] on a no parking
sign in little tokyo
to me like even if it was staged they
did such a good job that or
this occurs so much that it seems
realistic can you imagine staging that
like you produced that a guy to [ __ ] on
a no parking side
my best work i just feel like when it
comes to like
seeing things like feces or vomit and
entertainment
i'm more of like the i like the
extravagance i like when somebody's like
you know
in a script they're supposed to like
throw it but then it's just like quentin
tarantino blood style where it's like
and it's like just gallons more extreme
and it's like
if it's like really realistic it's just
like there's some sort of art to it
i see you turn up the volume on it a
little bit
yeah or like a scary movie or whatever
when the dude like busts a nut and then
it's just
when somebody gets beheaded and there's
just blood that's just like you almost
see the pipe still
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know even
spielberg was like
that's a lot of [ __ ] coffee
that's impressive i like motivated
by bodily fluids motivated like this
rock band i don't know what the
narrative is but then all of a sudden
this guy needs to vomit and i'm like
it seems like this this shock kind of
thing
yeah just for the sake of it rather than
like someone smelled something so bad
that they had a puke
yeah like what's the purpose well their
objective was specifically to get kicked
out
and i found that out later because they
were trying to start as much [ __ ] as
possible
to get kicked out and film the the whole
like kicking out so it's a principle
yeah exactly exactly yeah i would turn
the tables on them and be like
kicking out as you think throw up on the
store i'm going to tie you to a chair
and throw up on you
oh that's good they're like wait wait
that's too far and it's like nah [ __ ]
this is rock and roll or you tie them up
and [ __ ] in their lap
yeah i like that you stand on their
knees and then you just squat
right there and they're like that's cool
yeah that's assault so
you just scoop up their their vomit and
then you just like yeah
that's rock and roll so they rigged uh
like those
hidden cameras to see your guys's
reaction
bts guy and i could see when i came down
to talk to the dude that the bts guy was
like secretly like filming and i'm like
i'm not to give you that [ __ ]
because they wanted me to call the cops
and stuff you know how did they do
they're like yeah bro don't call the
cops don't do it man
he just hits 9-1 on my phone and gives
it back
cops call dude they're trying to
manufacture how badass they are yeah
exactly
that makes you want to kick their ass
exactly yeah that's so badass
you've seen the final video and
everything it's like do you guys look
do you guys look like a [ __ ] hall
monitor he didn't he didn't put me in it
but like it is i know what they were
trying to do and i was just like come on
yeah it looks like a ripoff of like a
title of the creator like early video
and i'm like come on
it's not even creative it's like how bad
your business now
no that was like one in every one in
every
100 bookings ends up as well i can talk
about them the more i want to look them
up and be a fan
yeah i want to find them
who rents her studios the most more
photo shoots or like music videos
um it seems like it's mostly just girls
doing real quick shoots for their
socials i like his business i like his
business a lot sad boyfriends taking
pictures
and sad boyfriends they're sulking the
whole time taking pictures
would you say it's more like the only
fans department or more
like the artsy fartsy department i it's
i think it's split down the middle but i
found a really interesting thing about
only fans
that blew my mind so there was a guy who
came in and he's an only fans
photographer
he came to the city he rotated like 10
girls did a bunch of shoots with him and
then he told me he goes
i own all the pages but all they do is
come in
and they just they get told what to wear
how to pose then they leave it's like 30
minutes tops
each girl the pages are all owned by
this one dude
and he even chats with everybody as if
it's them i knew there was a scam
today's video is brought to you by
amazon music
all right check this out guys they have
more than just
podcasts they have millions
and millions of streamable music
on amazon music you know why i know this
is because
i personally use when i when i have
alexa around
doesn't it feel like you have a personal
mate or something like that a personal
jukebox dj person and a friend yeah
like alexa play hawaiian music
i love that and i don't have to push a
button or anything like that it does it
for me yeah
yeah and then it's like i'm just lifting
weights
swimming in the pool yeah and i feel
like i'm back
on oahu baby yeah and i like that you
can give a mood too sometimes she's like
give me some hype music and you can see
is that what i was looking for
or can you chill me out music and you
can go oh is that what i was looking for
they have a pretty extensive playlist
all right so
for our listeners you can get this for
free just go to amazon.com
off the record and you don't need a
credit card no subscription required and
you get to listen
to thousands of music stations and over
10 million
podcast episodes just like this one go
to amazon.com
off the record to get your free music
streaming
that guy's [ __ ] genius genius he's a
pimp oh yeah he's a pimp basically and
he goes like yeah i got 12 pages i make
i make this much money like per thing
the girls got to cut the girls are
getting less
than he is they get the day rates
because all you gotta do is just show up
and they're not famous they don't even
have a lot of followers and he goes you
don't need a lot of followers you just
need like
crazy like five crazy dudes each girl
and they'll just shower them with the
gifts and stuff because he interacts and
does engagement
so these guys suck your dick
and he just [ __ ] loves it yeah holy
yeah isn't that crazy
and he said he said there's dozens more
guys like him
like holy [ __ ] so you're talking about
you're talking you're saying the only
fans chick i'm talking to right now is
that a dude
it could be hopefully 50 50 chance i
feel so violated
feeling that they were typing like a
dude hitting the keys all hard way too
many winky faces i don't buy it anymore
i knew she didn't like me genius planned
though that is pretty genius though
or isn't that just like a regular plan
like since like that's
always been happening yeah but like only
i guess only fans
the app is the new variable yeah but
supposed to be only fans is like this
entrepreneurial female empowerment
finally we own our bodies again
but no not really
there's still two's behind it there's
still some dudes behind it the little
dude behind that it gives you some hope
doesn't it yeah
yeah we were afraid of this we can take
back only fans yeah
it could be ours it could be our
platform too we were all afraid of this
emerging platform
like imagine a world without strippers
that's what was about to happen
yeah yeah they were all going to go to
only fans and strip club is going to be
empty
scary yeah strip clubs will never be
empty
that's crazy that's true
daytime strip clubs maybe will never be
have you guys done a daytime show
absolutely
i mean no well we were filming danger
boys when we were walking out of there
the daytime strippers were coming in
that was like 11 in the morning yeah
dude that's when the wings are good
though
wait what's the difference with the
daytime strippers they're like the
ones in training or the ones that aren't
the best how do i how do we put the
uh in trainings going
yeah so there's someone stripping next
to them telling them how to do it
a little more hips a little more like a
starbucks trainee yeah
they're the ones in like one leg or like
you know the
one of the tricks that came in was
telling the bouncer she's glad like she
doesn't have to dance pregnant anymore
or something
yeah it's not exactly the top brass
whoa it must be rough dude i don't know
dude there's a lot of never mind i'm not
even going to go there
say it say what are you going to say
pregnancy exercise said extra life
yeah i mean he just the other day said
that pregnant girls were hot right
yeah that's right yeah i think all
pregnant women are beautiful
no matter what that's not what he said
that's not what he said what did he say
did he say something like
he said cardi b is so [ __ ] hot when
she's pregnant
way hotter yeah for a pregnant [ __ ] he
qualified it oh so
she's pregnant pregnant is hotter
yeah because bart loves women the way
they are yeah yeah
trekking in all sizes he remembers
verbatim yeah
he yeah especially when they're pregnant
yes
he's changing the words around a little
bit but yes
i don't know about that one but yeah
that's fine i'm okay with it
we watch pregnant porn no never see even
ryan knows it's a genre
you like pregnant girls but you don't
watch pregnant porn it's a sacred thing
you don't wanna you don't wanna oh okay
so you just watch birthing videos
i admire from afar on the streets i go
oh wow what a beautiful scene
yeah on the streets what street is all
just pregnant with
a cedar cyanide
[Laughter]
you're just standing outside oh
beautiful hello i feel like you're
checking people in
you know just reading a newspaper like a
creep just outside uh
outside of obgyn a newspaper just makes
it so obvious you're just a holes in the
middle nobody reads newspapers no
problem
yo i found a newspaper at the airport
man it was the new york post i was so
shocked
and it still had the old [ __ ] greasy
ass
like letters on it that smears and i was
like dude i want to buy this just so i
could eat seafood on it
wait there's no newspapers anymore where
do you
find them have you seen them i haven't
been looking sometimes they end up on my
doorstep
passing the star news they just keep
giving up pasadena i feel like would
still do newspapers yeah but i'm like i
do have to pay for this like i didn't
sign up for this it's a part of like the
city fee that you like secretly pay for
already don't worry about your way for
the whole city of pasadena you've been
paying for it you've been paying for
like the
[ __ ] the gardener i see those coupon
papers but i don't see newspapers coupon
papers are newspapers
dude i was just in vegas and they didn't
nobody was doing the
oh no they didn't know the hot girls oh
really
i didn't see it yeah they still doing
you just gotta catch them at the right
time he was just there just two days i
was just there
they never looked like the girls in the
the card no they were the neon shirts
they don't called one of those are those
trip clubs or what is it for sure
who showed up a lot of things uh it was
just a really old lady
yeah they come up to your door it's a
private stripper
yeah it's like the same thing it's like
the same girl just like that was her
photo like 15 years ago
oh you actually called the number yeah
the girls i didn't call
but your friend called yeah my friend
your friend anthony called
have you ever called the topless mage
line
dude who's calling that but i called
them i see that were they hot
i see you know it's because there's a
this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] up story but
like i was managing airbnb and we needed
a maid for this particular day
all the maids were taken oh [ __ ] so i
had to call it [ __ ] i had to do it
yeah
she showed up she didn't have any
cleaning products
and i was like we just had a party and i
was like yo we need to clean this whole
house
and she goes you want me to clean she
doesn't [ __ ] clean
at all the top of me go clean i'm
shocked they don't clean
and then she goes okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna clean i guess give me the
product so i got her the [ __ ] gloves and
all so she starts cleaning and she goes
she takes her shirt off and she's like
all right uh so if anybody else walks
through and sees me that's another
50 bucks and then um i was like i don't
want to have to even see you but then
like the
uh was she hot at least the owner of the
house no she wasn't
you didn't go like just keep your shirt
back on you don't pay you extra
clean but the owner of the house was
like i want to make sure she doesn't
steal anything
don't take your eyes off her so i have
to [ __ ] stand there
your titties are hanging a conversation
with a topless maid
who's telling me all about how she's
really a registered nurse
no way yeah and she's just like well her
titties are hanging she's doing a shitty
job cleaning
it's like looks worse how much do they
make to do that i don't
think they make anything too clean yeah
she was super surprised that i actually
wanted to really clean
and she was like what the [ __ ] she's
she's like what are you [ __ ] larry
david
what is this [ __ ] well that's a curve
episode yeah yeah
she caught she caused almost as much as
our normal maid dude that's
an amazing story yeah sucks that's
hilarious
now i just want to go on the yellow
pages higher all like the weird things
you still got yellow pages or i don't
know what do you look like blank
whatever the blank is hire them for the
blank yeah but what the [ __ ]
would work mma trainer yelling birthday
clowns i can't see what this guy does
whatever yeah topless birthday clowns
birthday club so what are they supposed
to do just pretend to clean like they
get yeah
i think that's all they can do they're
just a show it's a show they're trying
to make it that's
what it is yeah it's a show you know
when you watch like the beast
and then you know lumiere and then he's
got the [ __ ] french like
feather duster a chick and when you're a
kid you're kind of like i know that
that's just a feather duster but i
[ __ ] it that's what it is you know the
chicken clue wasn't clean and [ __ ] by
the way
yeah she was very hot but she wouldn't
clean much not much at all no
well i don't know um if you
if you don't get to come why do people
pay for that
or maybe they do get it wait you like
the edge don't you bring the blanket out
and you go okay you're gonna clean now
then you put the blanket on your lap and
you start jacking away underneath the
blanket yeah you just see a handle
that's stealthy just newspapers holding
up
the ass newspaper you're supposed to
what's the proper etiquette do you go
yeah
it was so cold in here here's a blanket
is it a front for like a prostitution
thing
it might be i think i think it really is
i think that's like the foot in the door
like getting the maid come over and then
you propose
additional secret codes i'm learning so
much
would you like two avocados on the lime
and she goes oh yeah
and do you happen to do can plumbing
snake my drain please with this cat
she's like she's like oh you want me to
clean the house he's like yeah now clean
the house and she's like you want to
clean the house he's like yeah clean the
[ __ ] house
it's a mess she's like i'm gonna clean
the house so good he's like please
we can't do it as good as good as
possible yeah yeah she's all i don't
have any
products it's called windows give her
the [ __ ] lysol
she's like you're like what the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is that if you want me to put this
up my ass i'll do it because it's
extra i'm like don't worry just butt off
that's [ __ ] hello that's crazy by how
pissed she was
i would assume that she was expecting
the exact opposite so that's why i'm
like oh she's like why the [ __ ] do you
want me to clean i'm here to suck some
dick
she was so mad yeah but judging how
topless she was she still you know was
doing her job what's the
hourly rate uh it was like i forgot what
it was
i forgot what it was but it was hundreds
of bucks like for that's so funny that
you couldn't find one cup
there's not one like we should get a
topless made in here this place is kind
of dirty
just don't look and you'll save money
it's okay it's not like a one eye thing
it's like 25 we have a hot one we bring
out
six blankets hey guys
three blankets we all share we have bart
welcome them in and then we all pretend
like we're blind
no no don't worry don't worry we're just
poking her with a stick
under bart's one blanket that's your
product you need to make the snuggie
that's a fake
arm yeah coming out the right side
and and the belly so sleep like lincoln
is just going like that
yes shark tank let's go dude
yeah but the worst thing is you're
coming in your belly that's by far the
worst part
have you guys seen that kid on the
airplane who was
who had a blanket over his head and he
was beating off like no tomorrow
and it's so funny because the light the
window was open so it was a creative
silhouette and you can see exactly what
this is
wait i gotta see this video
no you could see how furiously he's
going man it's like a 20 silhouette
photo but just like
video format yeah the whole blank was
the secret climb though that's how you
know that's how you that's how you
finish
so now the trait the tray table is down
he's just
he just does it with the turbulence just
waits
it lets the turbulence control come on
pilot stop flying so smooth
you